was haben adam und eva mit der hektik
unseres alltags zu tun warum wollen von
rechts bis links von der afg bis zur
occupy bewegung immer alle etwas an der
welt verändern und niemand lässt die
dinge auf sich beruhen versuchen auch
sie persönlich ständig weiter zu kommen
weil sie den stillstand fürchten die
unruhe sei das alles bestimmende
lebensgefühl der modernen und zeit sagt
der kieler philosoph ralf konersmann und
zeigt mit einer spannenden
kulturgeschichtlichen tiefenbohrung dass
dies so alles andere als
selbstverständlich ist aber so porentief
in uns verankert
das hier ist schon gar nicht mehr merken
dass man herzlich und in aller ruhe
heiße ich sie in unserem studio
willkommen
die buchhandlungen sind ja voll derzeit
von ratgebern wie burnout nein danke
entschleunigen dich und so haben sie
eine erklärung dafür warum ihr schön
geschrieben ist aber doch
anspruchsvolles philosophisches buch 460
seiten sind es die unruhe der welt in
unserer angeblich so gehetzt und seit
seinem bestseller geworden ist als autor
hat man mühe wenn es ein solcher erfolg
ist sich das zu erklären und das
interesse des großen publikums ich muss
mir das auch zusammenbleiben
am meisten überzeugt mich die these die
ich eigentlich auch in dem buch vertrete
dass diese ratgeber ein wenig zu kurz
springen die probleme an der oberfläche
behandeln und keine erklärung dafür
anbieten warum wir so ein zweideutiges
verhältnis zur unruhe haben die unruhe
ist natürlich eine last und auf diese
erfahrung reagieren die ratgeber aber
andererseits wissen wir doch alle dass
wir die unruhe lieben und dass wir dafür
begeistern können dass wir sie gar nicht
missen möchten und das ist eine
interessante zweideutigkeit und die hat
mich dazu bewogen etwas tiefer zu bohren
aber freut man sich schon als autor wenn
die leute danach schreien oder ist man
als philosoph ein bisschen gestört in
seinem elfenbeinturm
nein das glaube ich nicht also ich bin
kein kritiker des elfenbeinturms weil
so ein rückzug sehr wichtig ist um dinge
ausprobieren zu können um gedanklich
auch experimentieren zu können aber
irgendwann muss man dann eben mal raus
und das natürlich eine große freude wenn
man offenbar den nerv der zeit getroffen
hat die medien die radiostationen die
zeitungen rennen ihnen die studiert er
ein sozusagen was holen sie in diesem
buch ans licht was die anderen eben
nicht gesehen haben
zunächst einmal das was ich schon sagte
die zweideutigkeit der unruhe und die
tiefe das heißt dass sie eigentlich die
westlichen zivilisation ich kann mich
aus kompetenz gründen überhaupt nur über
die westlichen zivilisationen hier
äußern und zu den äußern dass also die
unruhe zivilisations begleitendes
element ist
wir haben die unruhe immer gehabt wir
haben sie nur unterschiedlich besetzt
und deswegen kann man eine geschichte
dieser unruhe schreiben die meisten oder
viele sagen die unruhe ist ein mit der
moderne oder erst recht mit dem
internetzeitalter über uns
hereingebrochen und sie schreiben das
sei ein irrtum zunächst was meinen sie
genau mit der unruhe die da über uns
einbricht
die unruhe zu definieren ist unendlich
schwer weil zu der unruhe selbst auch
ein bestimmtes unbestimmtheit moment
gehört und wir haben zahlreiche
beschreibungen der unruhe das fängt mit
der theologie an die das ganze in den in
den diskurs der sünde einbezieht in der
unruhe ein zeichen ein zeichen das
verhängnis ist er gefallen hat sieht und
dann haben dann folgen eine ganze reihe
anderer beschreiben wir haben politische
beschreibung der unruhe wir haben
theologische beschreibung der unruhe
soziologische beschreibung der unruhe
darauf haben sie an gespielt die
sogenannte beschleunigung
ich bin deshalb skeptisch bei all denen
die meinen die unruhe sei ein phänomen
der moderne
weil wir sie eben schon lange vorher
kannten und weil auch die beschleunigung
eine aus meiner sicht ungenaue
beschreibung ist wir haben die unruhe
zugelassen
haben hemmungen abgebaut wir haben
blockaden abgebaut wir haben
behinderungen abgebaut und der unruhe
immer mehr raum gegeben so würde ich die
situation beschreiben
vor wenigen monaten hatten wir an diesem
tisch als gast in soziologe hartmut rosa
berlin sagt das hat mit der
beschleunigung auch mit dem internet mit
der digital zu tun und eben sie sagen
herzhaft das abendland ist gehetzt von
unruhig und viel viel länger das fängt
also mindestens bei adam und eva an
das fängt bei adam und eva an die eben
mit dem paradies mit dem ort der ruhe
der passung von ich und welt das ist ja
ein sehnsucht motiv denken sie an die
romantik das ist immer eine sehnsucht
motiv gewesen und umso unfassbarer ist
es das erste menschenpaar dem all dies
schon geschenkt war das ist ja der
inbegriff des paradieses dass diese
chance diese situation vertan wurde und
schon in der nächsten generation von den
söhnen von adam und eva und speziell von
kein nun vollends verspielt wird und er
dann von jack w vertrieben wird vollends
vertrieben wird auch auf der paradies
nähe in der sich immerhin adam und eva
nach der ersten vertreiber noch halten
durften hat die unruhe kommt in zwei
stufen die kommen sozusagen in zwei
stufen ja zunächst einmal die irritation
aus der paradies welt vertrieben zu sein
in eine vollkommen unbekannte welt
unbekannt heißt hier auch es wird
überhaupt erstmals die erfahrung mit
unbekanntheit gemacht im paradies war
eben alles so es fügte sich sozusagen
alles menschen gemäß von sich aus alle
bedürfnisse wurden vorgreifen bedient
und es gab überhaupt keine bedürfnisse
die nicht hätten befriedigt werden
können und plötzlich das phänomen
unbekannt hat und als zweite stufe dann
die erfahrung kainz die erfahrung der
unruhe
ich war rastlos und unruhe unruhig wirst
du sein weil er den bruder erschlagen
aber als strafe weil er den bruder
erschlagen hat weil er sich gott
gegenüber freiheiten genommen hat er
glaubte gott würde ihn nicht beobachten
können und so ein ganzes konglomerat
aber diese figur des kein blatt
nun endlich platzt noch blasser bleibt
aber es geht ich glaube diese ganze
geschichte des alten testaments ist im
nachhinein erfunden wurden von menschen
die erklärung dafür gesorgt gesucht
haben warum leben wir eigentlich so
unruhig warum können wir nicht stehen
bleiben warum müssen wir uns immer
bewegen warum müssen wir immer verändern
und das ist eine erklärung im nachhinein
zu sagen das ist eine plausible
geschichte und diese geschichte war
immerhin tragfähig genug um uns bis an
die grenzen der neuzeit zu überzeugen
unruhe ist etwas sinnhaftes etwas was
wir hinter uns lassen müssen und da gibt
es dann mehrere varianten dieser
geschichte eine offenbar ausgesprochen
fruchtbare information gewesen aber sie
sagen
in der realität war die unruhe da kann
man sagen das ist die conditio humana
auch als unsere vorfahren in höhlen
lebten dabei erwartete draußen und man
musste kämpfen zum überlegen die unruhe
gehört zum menschlichen leben
auch das ist eine geschichte die erzählt
worden ist ja von platon erstmals dass
der mensch ein wesen ist das mit sich
selbst nicht auskommt weil es mängel hat
weil es die situation dies
hineingeworfen ist gestalten muss weil
es aufgefordert ist aufgrund seiner
körperlichen defizite aufgefordert ist
die mit der situation irgend etwas
anzupacken anzufangen sich die welt
wohnlich einzurichten dass er nur eine
andere geschichte
aber im grunde wissenschaftler
naturwissenschaft zu werden sagen dass
mehr als eine geschichte das war ebenso
die reaktion der mensch entwickelt sich
und der berg steht vor der höhle der bär
steht vor der höhle und vieles andere
wir können krank werden wir müssen uns
um unsere nahrung kümmern wir müssen sie
herbeischaffen wir müssen sie zu
bereiten und und und das heißt wir
müssen eine kultur einrichten und diese
kultur hat nun das große problem das
sieht auch schon platon und viele andere
dass sie selbst ein ort der unruhe ist
ja also das heißt es ist nicht so dass
wir nun in der unruhe leben aus der
höhle heraus kommen tun was zu tun ist
und uns wieder zurückziehen können und
wieder in der hohe landen
das ist leider eine illusion wenn man
erst einmal angefangen hat die höhle zu
verlassen
und dies und jenes zu tun dann
entwickeln sie entwickeln sich
eigenlogik die allesamt in die unruhe
führen oder die unruhe lebendig halten
und seitdem begleitet uns die sehnsucht
oder doch zumindest für eine sehr lange
zeit hat er uns die sehnsucht begleitet
in die ruhe zurückzukehren und so ein
wort wie entschleunigung zeigt dass wir
das immer noch nicht so ganz vergessen
haben und sie sagen die bibel hat das
auf eine ganz geniale weise getan dass
das jahrtausende oder über ein
jahrtausend funktioniert hat und die
leute getröstet hat getröstet hat weil
immer präsent gehalten wurde die idee es
gibt eine ruhe gott hat die welt so
eingerichtet
er hat wir hatten hatte saßen schon
einmal den ruhe es gab ja das paradies
also ich rede jetzt immer sozusagen in
den grenzen der der theologischen
information
und warum sollen wir denn diese ruhe
nicht wieder erlangen
und dann gibt es sozusagen ganz zwei
ganz zentrale auskünfte das eine ist
dass wir im tod zurückfinden in die ruhe
ruhe in frieden diese formel kommt schon
sehr früh auf im laufe des mittelalters
und ist ja heute noch gebräuchlich und
die andere information ist da kommt
schon im vierten jahrhundert der
kirchenlehrer augustinus darauf dass die
unruhe vielleicht nicht ein sie ist ein
übel aber vielleicht nicht nur ein übel
weil sie uns erlaubt uns auf die ewige
ruhe vorzubereiten das hat ihr leben
nicht einfach nur so dahin
sondern wir führen ein geordnetes schon
im blick auf die ruhe zu führen das
leben augustinus dass einer der großen
denker musste jedoch eine erklärung
finden weil wenn die unruhe in der welt
ist und gott alles geschaffen habt dann
hat man gar keine wahl die musste
positiv gedeutet werden sie musste
positiv gedeutet werden aber natürlich
ambivalent nicht das unruhige herz von
dem augustinus in seinen bekenntnissen
spricht
ist einerseits ein zeichen dass wir nie
vergessen wer wir sind wir sind
diejenigen die am anfang der zeiten
gesündigt haben und verspielt haben was
uns einmal geschenkt war auf der anderen
seite steckt aber auch ein gnaden motiv
darin weil diese unruhe so ambivalent
ist dass sie einerseits den schaden an
zeigt das übel und andererseits auch die
rettung verheißt und so können wir die
unruhe einsetzen selbst beobachtend
durch die führung eines gottgefälligen
lebens das uns geradezu bereit macht um
eines tages in ruhe an der seite gottes
und seines sohnes zu leben oder wenn man
das so nennen kann jedenfalls den
ewiggestrigen in ewigkeit zu sein
was bringt es nun diesen biblischen
erzählungen wie sie es tun die tiefe in
alle feinheiten nachzuspüren gehen sie
davon aus dass das noch nachricht auch
wenn die kirchenbänke heute oft leer
oder viele lehrer sind als damals die
mit land also ich spreche ja nicht als
theologe sondern was diese dinge angeht
als ideen historiker vielleicht auch als
als mythen forscher was auch immer
was mich daran interessiert ist die
plausibilisierung die eine solche
geschichte leistet und diese
plausibilisierung leistung ist ja
keineswegs verloren die geschichte mag
verloren seinen die ihren details aber
diese details werden immer wieder
fruchtbar gemacht in literarischen
texten aber auch über werbung oder in
hollywood in von der traumfabrik werden
diese motive immer wieder aufgegriffen
in ihren schon noch da hat die sind alle
noch da wehrleute nicht sagen nicht
richte mich nicht nach der video aber
gewiss der kein muss nicht immer kein
heißen aber es gibt auch hollywood-filme
es ist auch ein film über kein jetzt
wieder in vorbereitungen blockbuster
soll es sogar werden also das läuft
alles ständig mit ja diese auch diese
überzeugung dass es das wir dass die
unruhe dieser ambivalenz hat und so
weiter da muss man glaube ich gar nicht
so viele worte machen das versteht jeder
der sozusagen in unserem kultur
kulturellen zusammenhängen unterwegs ist
diese deutungsmuster sind das
entscheidende
diese art sich diese welt zurecht zu
legen und der mythos hat das halt in
perfekter form insofern vorbereitet und
darf sich man darf ja bei mythos nie
vergessen das sind ja ursprünglich
mündliche erzählungen die über viele
generationen weitergereicht und in auch
in vielen situationen erzählt wurden sie
sind sozusagen glatt geschliffen und
insofern perfekt es ist nicht ein autor
sondern ganz viele erzähler die diesen
mythos eine bleibende gestalt gegeben
haben deswegen auch seine formale
perfektion und auch seine variabilität
wir haben ja schon mit augustinus
jemanden kennengelernt der aufseher
kluge weise mit dem mythos umgegangen
ist und ihn re formuliert hat so dass er
für die nächsten jahrhunderte wieder
tragfähig war das alles nur für das
abendland ist die unruhe nur unser
problem sozusagen schwer zu sagen
schwer zu sagen ich beschränke mich
wohlweislich auf die westlichen
traditionen weil ich da einfach die
meiste kompetenz habe und weil ich mir
auch nicht anmaßen würde über die
anderen kulturen zu schreiben sie haben
sicher eine ganz ähnliche
herausforderung aber aktions biologisch
haben wir alle das gleiche mit bekommen
wir müssen gegen die bern die tiger die
löwen kämpfen eine elementar krise
interessiert sie das als philosoph oder
sagen sie ich schaue nur die geschichten
haben oder auch wie die menschen konkret
gelebt habe nein das interessiert mich
natürlich auch ja bis heute und heute
über die gegenwart gibt es ja noch keine
geschichten sondern wir greifen alte
geschichten auf und was wir dort für
bewältigungsstrategien haben was andere
kulturen für bewältigungsstrategien das
ist natürlich alles hochinteressant aber
zunächst einmal galt es natürlich
sozusagen unsere eigene geschichte noch
einmal ans licht zu heben und zu zeigen
wie machen wir es eigentlich selber und
wo sind wir vielleicht
stich oder wo fangen wir an uns allzu
sehr an bestimmte dinge zu gewöhnen so
dass wir schon achselzucken darüber
hinweg gehen wir als philosophen stehen
ja nicht unbedingt unter originalität
drückt druck wir müssen nicht das
spektakuläre suchen uns genügt es das zu
beschreiben und sauber zu rekonstruieren
wovon alle ausgehen dass es so oder so
ähnlich wohl sein müsste
auch wer nicht allzu viel von östlicher
philosophie weiß weiß dass dort mit der
meditation vermutlich eine praxis wie
man zu einem ruhigen zustand kommt wie
näher liegt oder oder oder explizit da
vermittelt wird könnt ihr sagen dass
oder haben sie eine genaue definition
für die ruhe
die ruhe ist das was uns am meisten
abhanden gekommen ist und ich könnte als
erklärung anbieten dass das christentum
in der nachfolge des augustinus in der
nachfolge natürlich des protestantismus
der ein aufgeschlossenes verhältnis
sagen wir einmal zum arbeitenden
menschen hat und die gott gefälligkeit
der lebensbewältigung beschrieben hat
das nun also das christentum selber
irgendwann nicht mehr als hüter der ruhe
wahrgenommen worden ist sondern als eine
religion deren dogmatik uns nun auch
auffordert in irgendeiner weise tätig
und rührig zu sein
das heißt der wesentliche unterschied
zur parade situation ist in der paradies
situation ist der mensch angenommen da
muss gar nichts tun ist einfach als der
der er ist angenommen die christlichen
ethik gehen mehr und mehr dazu über so
eine bewährungs logik aufzubauen also
wenn du schon angenommen werden willst
dann aber bitte auch dies oder jenes
leisten
ja und da kommt dann kommen dann
religionen auf und werden attraktiv und
das fängt ja schon ende des 18
jahrhunderts an dass man schaut wie ist
das mit den östlichen religionen in der
romantik schopenhauer usw
was bieten die eigentlich an und ist es
da vielleicht in gewisser weise
komfortabler muss man da nicht erst mal
was leisten bevor man
in die ruhe kommen darf ja und da ist
eine ein gewisser umschlag der da
deutlich wird und auch der dann uns auch
was sagt über das was wie das
christentum mit der unruhe umgegangen
ist und uns mit der unruhe versöhnt hat
da kommen doch dann auch bei den
benediktinern sehr früh diese
aufforderungen ora et labora bete und
arbeite also man muss etwas tun das
gehört wohl zur bewährung alles würde
ich sagen
erklärungen die mich vielleicht trösten
die es mir leichter machen oder dick der
unruhe unter anstrengung einen sinn
geben jetzt habe ich aber fasziniert in
ihrem buch gelesen weil sie das wirklich
auch sehr schön auf den punkt bringen
dann kommt ein moment wo man nicht nur
so sagt okay man muss halt oder es ist
für die ewigkeit gut sich anstrengen
sondern jetzt verliebt sich sozusagen
das abendland irgendwann nein erinnern
gewissen bestimmten moment in die unruhe
beschreiben ist ein moment wo das
abendland das nicht nur so hinnimmt
sondern sagt war unruhe ist eigentlich
was supergutes ja also das ist die
neuzeit ja man könnte fast eine
definition der neuzeit aus dieser
umstellung und erneuerung ziehen die wir
zeitlich ansetzen was 15 jaja wende zum
zu 17 jahrhundert nicht war ausgangs der
renaissance irgendwo spricht von früher
neuzeit wenn es noch nicht die
aufklärung ist absichtlich ein ganz vage
eine vage orientierung und es hat ja
auch niemand auf irgendein klingelknopf
gedrückt und dann ging es los sondern
das ist ein übergang widersprüchlicher
übergang auch umkämpft umstritten
denken sie an sie figuren wie galilei
denken sie an die kraft der auch nicht
unbedingt schreiben durfte was er wollte
also aber eben von einigen protagonisten
mutig voran getrieben eine
uminterpretation der unruhe
das was augustinus selbstverständlich
immer noch ein gehegt hat er schreibt ja
vor eine der vor dem horizont im
horizont einer klaren durch die
schöpfung definierten wirklichkeit
dieses bricht irgendwann auf und man
sagt eben uns menschen ist doch da etwas
gegeben etwas ungeheures eine energie
eine macht und warum sollen wir sie denn
nicht so einsetzen dass wir selbst auch
einen gehörigen beitrag leisten nicht
nur für uns selbst nicht nur für unsere
seele sondern um die wirklichkeit neu zu
gestalten
ich war und da kommt dann so eine figur
wie francis bacon und sagt im bereich
des wissens und der wissenschaften als
einem jahr 238 denn das war ja für einer
was er war laut kanzler eine sehr
prominente figur in der englischen
gesellschaft und darüber hinaus und
philosophisch ausgesprochen ambitioniert
auch sehr gelehrt erkannte vor allen
dingen die antiken autoren die
scholastika com weniger bei ihm vor
aber das kam natürlich entgegen weil er
einen neuanfang auch setzen wollte er
war sich dessen sehr bewusst und nun
also in einem relativ gesellschaftlich
abgeteilten bereich nämlich im bereich
des wissens das alles in einem
esoterischen bereich wenn sie so wollen
es einmal mit der unruhe ausprobieren
und dann kommen solche motive auf wie
neugierig sein sich nicht zufrieden
geben immer weiter suchen hunger nach
wissen diese ganzen metaphern brechen
plötzlich alle auf werden
zusammengetragen und es ändert sich
daneben auch das bild der neugier das
wird plötzlich zu einer tugend sich
nicht mit dem zufrieden zu geben was man
schon zu wissen glaubt oder sogar noch
nach zu setzen das stimmt das überhaupt
was wir alles klar und da haben wir
genau diese grundmotive der aufklärung
und die sind ja heute noch im
wesentlichen intakt geblieben das hat
mich auch gefahren
der satz zum beispiel den sie da in
meinem buch drin haben die unruhe ist
natürlich auch richtig sie eine welt
voller fantasien voller verheißungen und
pläne habe ich gedacht es stimmt doch
was junger mensch das empfindet man
christian mamas aus aus dem leben und
sie zeigen auch das gesicht der unruhe
ist es heute in unserer gegenwart
was fast überall und lustig ist doch
auch zu
beobachten dass die menschen bei uns das
auch in den 60er jahren heute gibt es
fortschritt skepsis aber damals auch in
der schweiz wurde das sehr freudig
empfangen und die leute hießen die neue
unruhe und umtriebigkeit herzhaft
willkommen
da gibt es original töne eine autobahn
handwerk gebaut die journalisten des
fernsehens an damals hingegangen weil
wie findet ihr das und wir sehen die
leute haben sich regelrecht auf die
autobahn gefahren
ich hatte
während liste
das stammt aus dem film a 1 ein streifen
schweizerstraße den der in der schweiz
bekannte komiker und schauspieler mike
müller mit seinem bruder gehe dreht hat
und wo er will zeigt wie die schweiz
sich beschleunigt hat indem autobahnen
hier quer durch die landschaft gelegt
wurden und meine damen und herren diesen
film zeigen wir dann in der sternstunde
kunst gleich anschließen dann unser
gespräch geht irgendwie auch um das
thema unruhe und fortschrittsglaube
fortschritts waren würden gewisse sagen
es wurde damals selbst die laut der
autobahn herzlich willkommen geheißen
sie würden sagen aber heute wir sind
auch noch kinder der unruhe die mode
zählen sie zu den phänomenen wo wir der
definition darum kritik bleiben die bode
das reden über krisen ja wir haben ganz
viele möglichkeiten uns die ruhe unruhe
zurechtzulegen und schön zu reden und
aber sagte sie noch ein bisschen warum
ist mode gleich unruhe
die mode ist insofern die unruhe als sie
nichts anderes ist als der wechsel
es hat überhaupt keinen sinn bei der
mode nach sinn oder nach bestimmten
inhalten zu fragen sondern sie mutet und
saison für saison beliebiges zu und wir
spielen dieses spiel mit wir sind
allenfalls neugierig darauf zu erfahren
was was jetzt diesmal sich die
entscheider ausgedacht haben und wo es
worum es diesmal gehen soll
und das geht ja nicht nur bei der
kleidermode so denken sie damit an den
enthusiasmus mit dem etwa neue handys
oder innovationen in dem bereich
vermeldet werden das ist ja sogar
nachrichten thema ja was ist jetzt
wieder neues gibt und so weiter das
heißt das ist geht weit über den bereich
der kleidung hinaus diese faszination
für etwas das uns überraschen soll da
sind wir wie kinder
dass da plötzlich etwas gemacht wird
oder etwas möglich ist und für uns
erreichbar sein soll
und da willigen wir alle ein und da gibt
es ja die merkwürdigsten
verhaltensweisen dass da leute
campieren und um das erste gerät zu
bekommen und so weiter und so weiter
das zeigt die ungeheure faszination die
davon ausgeht und ob so gibt es einige
gesellschaftliche felder und kulturelle
verhaltensweisen die immer wieder darauf
hinauslaufen uns in gewisser weise auf
trab zu halten
und bloß nicht bloß nicht still zu
stehen auf trab halten werden sie auch
die fitness studios entstand natürlich
das bewegen das bewegt sein
die versicherungen gehen ja mittlerweile
dazu über und in deutschland hat
offenbar jetzt auch eine versicherung
dass angekündigt diejenigen zu bei den
prämien zu begünstigen die nachweisen
können dass sie sich in bewegung halten
dass sie joggen und das gibt alles
pluspunkte bei der versicherung das
heißt nutzer relativ bedenkliche ganz
offensichtlich bedenkliche entwicklungen
gesellschaftliche entwicklungen aber um
noch mal kurz auf den film an zu spielen
viele leute spüren natürlich die unruhe
und verspüren sie auch als bedrohung
nicht nur weil sie persönlich betroffen
sind und womöglich ein burnout-syndrom
erlernen oder oder merken dass sie
abends nicht schlafen können sondern
weil sie auch merken es gibt eine eine
gesellschaftliche pflicht verpflichtung
sich einzulassen und nicht abgehängt zu
werden nicht und das erzeugt unbehagen
auf der einen seite fördert aber auch
wieder auf einer bestimmten anderen
ebene ängste und eben unruhe und wir
sind ja auch routiniert darin leute
damit zu bedrohen dass sie nicht
mitkommen denkt sie an so formulierungen
wie sitzenbleiben was ist denn da dieses
alte schulstraße des sitzenbleibens
anders als ein ausschluss von der
karawane die weiter zieht ja die weiter
die versetzt werden die anderen müssen
sitzen bleiben und dieses sitzen bleiben
das hat etwas du darfst ebenso zu sagen
die idee in dieser routine der
veränderungen dass du wirst du nicht
mitgenommen du gehörst nicht mehr dazu
so oder so etwas wie sitzen gelassen
werden ja schlimmer fast schlimmer als
die verlorene liebe ist ja da die
erfahrung dass man nun nicht mehr dazu
gehört offenbar also das ja auch schon
bei früheren stemmen die schlimmste
strafe ausgeschlossen
vater stirbt also ja verband zu sein
schlimmer als die tun
in den artikeln wollen sie in ihrem buch
genau dies aufdecken dass ohne das ist
in der packungsbeilage unserer kultur
sehr explizit immer betont wird dass
hier gewisse grundregeln die jedes
individuum betreffen die mich antreibt
im hamsterrad mit zu spurten dass die
fast zu verstecken wollen sie die
veröffentlichen ist das ein bisschen der
warnruf dieses buches jan und ich habe
ja natürlich ein zweideutiges verhältnis
zur unruhe nachzufragen und zu schauen
was es mit der unruhe auf sich hat ist
ja selber eine elementar geste der
unruhe sich sozusagen mit der unruhe
nicht zufrieden zu geben und sich nicht
zu beruhigen
also insofern bin ich verstrickt in
dieses thema andererseits und das hat
man etwas mit der wahrheit dieses titel
begriffs zu tun gilt es natürlich all
die bereiche aufzusuchen wo den die
unruhe haust sich verstärkt und wir
bereit sind uns auf sie einzulassen und
die mode oder die lebenslange bildung
und viele oder eben die
verkehrssituation das sind ja alles so
felder
da muss der begriff der unruhe gar nicht
vorkommen und wir werden da auch nicht
gelockt mit der unruhe sondern wir tun
es und das genügt ich weiß philosophen
regen nicht so gerne über sich selber
aber die marxisten haben ja gesagt die
wahrheit das konkret und man muss das
immer genau anschauen also wie halten
sie es damit
henschel ist sind sie ein philosoph der
doch sich distanz nimmt sagen
elfenbeinturm ist gar nicht übel oder
gehen sie in einer entschleunigung
scores oder mindestens ins fitnessstudio
nun habe ich natürlich als private das
privileg als hochschullehrer mir auch
die zeit zu nehmen ein solches buch zu
schreiben
es wird auch an der universität immer
weniger komfortabel da gibt es auch
immer mehr initiativen und
aufforderungen in gremien und sonstwo
tätig zu sein dass die zeit wird knapp
aber das buch zeigt ja dass man sie sich
noch nehmen kann und dass ich zurück
gezogen buchstäblich ja das musste auch
sein
sonst wäre das buch nicht zustande
gekommen ich habe da mehrere jahre daran
geschrieben und viele wochenenden
natürlich auch geopfert aber das
schreiben selber und das ist ein ganz
altes motiv das schreiben selbst hat
natürlich etwas eminent beruhigendes
weil es hilft die gedanken zu sortieren
sie auch in einer bestimmten
geschwindigkeit in der nämlich in der
schreibgeschwindigkeit vor augen zu
stellen und schon montani die ganzen
essay von monterrey des renaissance
denkers und schriftstellers sind nichts
anderes so beschreibt es auch morgan
stanley als die wirren gedanken im kopf
herum rennen da spricht er sogar von
einem fliegenden pferd das war sagt dass
dann auch an der novelle daraus zu
machen ja ja ja ich weiß gar nicht ob
war aber weil es ja auch ein kluger kerl
da wird das schon gewusst haben wo er
sehr hat also das wieder einzufangen und
zuschauer und die ganzen se also dass
sie über diese über 1000 seiten der
selbstreflexion sind nicht nur eine eine
bloßstellung des eigenen selbst sondern
sind auch eine beruhigung und im letzten
jahr sagt dann auch moderne ich habe es
geschafft nachdem er also jahrzehnte an
dem buch geschrieben hat er hat es
geschafft aber würden sie sagen für sie
ist das schreiben eine methode um ruhe
zu finden
ja das schreiben ganz bestimmt ja und
sonst noch nun sicher also älter werden
ist es sowieso schon jetzt sozusagen
eine natürliche unterstützung des
ruhiger werdens des bedächtiger werden
dass besonnener werdens und das kann man
natürlich auch bewusst verstärken dass
man also nicht gleich auf alles
aufspringen dass man sich überlegt muss
das jetzt eigentlich sein usw
aline erlebnis als verlust wenn man
nicht mehr mitkommt wie früher
vergleichen
kraft mehr energie erleben sie nicht als
leiten nein nein es ist ja auch so dass
man dem zunehmendem alter auch sieht wie
viele dinge einem erspart geblieben sind
weil man sie verpasst hat und man froh
ist der sie hat diese einsichten häufen
sich ja dass man froh ist dass man
dieses nicht auch noch auf sich genommen
also wir sehen wo wir es wissen und
wollen oder nicht manchmal fasziniert
oder spielen jedenfalls mit im großen
spiel der unruhe aber so
kulturgeschichtlich gesehen kann man
sagen die begeisterung die damit bacon
angefangen hat und hochgehalten wurde
irgendwann gibt es einen bruch
wahrscheinlich spätestens wenn die
gesagt gott ist tot dann dann gibt es
diese ganzen tröstenden richtungen nicht
mehr richtung paradies ewigkeit wo
setzen sie den bruch an wo diese
verliebtheit diese liebe zur unruhe
plötzlich auseinander rieselt also im
grunde schon bei pascal pascal ist eine
ganz interessante mitte des 17
jahrhunderts und der sich das anschaut
was darum sie um ihn herum geschieht
bacon galilei descartes viele andere
noch den nicht ganz so nicht ganz so
prominent sind der aber als theologe
oder zumindest der auf ihn erschienen
ist ein kloster in sogenannter solitär
der imperial lebt also in den
klösterlichen zusammenhang und der sieht
was was da geschieht und der sagt dir
lasst euch jetzt auch wenn er ganz neue
zeit an
deshalb man muss sehen dass descartes
oder bacon zwar was neues anfangen
wollten und das auch gesehen haben dass
sie es tun aber niemals auf die idee
gekommen wäre dass sie eine epochen
schwelle überschreiten sondern das sind
alles welten sagt das auch ganz deutlich
was ich hier heute euch sage das ist
jetzt eigentlich das richtige
verständnis der heiligen schrift gott
hat das gewollt sonst hätte er auch doch
gar nicht die unruhe gegeben
und das haben wir doch immer schon
gewusst dass eine gottesgabe ja so
argumentiert baic noch er will keine
revolution oder so etwas jedenfalls
nicht im sinne des späteren sinne dieses
wortes revolutionär wird kein schnitt
sondern er möchte einlösen was immer
schon gewollt war
und pascal ist der erste der sagt das
ist kein anschluss was er da macht das
ist kein weiter so sondern es etwas ganz
neues und seit der überhaupt darauf
vorbereitet wisst ihr überhaupt auf was
ihr euch da einen last- und dieser
dieser diese skepsis sozusagen das mal
vorsichtig die setzt sich fort und ich
würde sagen am spektakulärsten bricht
sie dann auf zwischen voltaire und
rousseau wo so der mit der natur noch
einmal so etwas schaffen möchte wie eine
metaphysische instanz die uns
orientierung gibt er spricht
gelegentlich von gott aber das populäre
was populär geblieben ist an rousseau
ist ja die natur dass da etwas ist woran
wir uns halten können das über jede
situation über jede zufälligkeit erhaben
ist und uns als richtschnur dienen kann
wollte er möchte das aufgeben wollte er
möchte dass wir uns in die welt wie
einen garten einrichten und diesen
garten und kultivieren müssen kühl tw
das ist das letzte wort des seines
großen romans konditor so sagt nein wir
haben die natur wir müssen uns an das
halten was schon da ist davon können wir
lernen
daran können wir uns orientieren und
diese zweideutigkeit im umgang mit dem
was jetzt folgt was jetzt zu tun ist
wollte er bringt es auf die polemische
formel lethargie tut also fleck mäuse
und und zurückgezogenheit und gleichmut
auf der einen seite und auf der anderen
seite heraus die herausforderung
annehmen und eine welt gestalten oft
nennen sie den begriff im buch die große
erzählung ich denke dass wahrscheinlich
die franzosen versuche jetzt hier
niemanden zu verwechseln aber die
strukturalismus so groß sie haben
das team eingebracht diese idee dass
eine gesellschaft gros eine große
erzählung hat nach der sich alle
ausrichten und die sagen das war so noch
viel länger als man vielleicht gedacht
hat er auch nach dem rationalisten noch
die große erzählung wie früher und ist
sie dann irgendwann ganz weg oder sie
ist unser problem dass wir keine
gemeinsame große abteilung mehr haben
sagen wir die großen erzählungen sind
sicher zerbrochen und wir werden keinen
konsens mehr erzeugen über eine große
erzählung dazu ist eben die unruhe zu
weit fortgeschritten sagen wir mal in
gestalt einer kritik die kritik ist
natürlich auch ein eminenter unruhe
faktor aber wir haben bruchstücke dieser
alten erzählungen wir bestimmte
assoziationsketten bestimmte
orientierungs muster haben sich erhalten
und deswegen bleiben diese alten
geschichten interessant weil sie immer
wieder aufgegriffen worden sind weil er
diese mythen ja auch eine
rezeptionsgeschichte haben
aufmerksamkeit immer wieder gefunden
haben an den überraschenden stellen
immer wieder auftauchen und uns insofern
wenn auch in zerlegter und verteilter
form erhalten geblieben sind weil ihre
plausibilisierung funktion sich erhalten
hat trotzdem wird oft gesagt das sei ein
mangel oder es macht uns das leben
schwer viele philosophen in ihren
vorträgen sagen man kann keine vision
keine utopie mehr haben das hat die
geschichte probiert das ist weg konnte
habe ich mich halt gefragt ist es
wirklich so wichtig die große erzählung
für die leben von uns als einzeln jeder
einzelne hat doch seine vision will das
ist ein kindern gut getarnt sein
warum ist die große erzählung überhaupt
so wichtig für den einzelnen und es
genügt nicht
persönliche privat der hoffnung zu haben
wir doch heute noch haben weil es auch
ein starkes bedürfnis nach gemeinsamkeit
gibt
ich nenne diese gemeinsamkeit kultur
also das worüber wir uns einig sind ohne
dass wir uns groß verständigen müssten
das wären vertrag ab
müssen oder überhaupt artikulieren
müssten worum es jetzt und es geht ja
wir haben einen fundus von
gemeinsamkeiten von von dingen von denen
wohl wird davon ausgehen können dass wir
es ganz ähnlich sehen und uns nicht
eigens verabreden müssten ja und dieser
raum der muss natürlich erhalten bleiben
sonst würde auch gar nichts mehr
funktionieren wenn jeder jetzt seine
eigenen sprachen seine eigenen wertungen
und so weiter ins spiel bringen würde
wer am ende gar keine kommunikation
keine zusammenarbeit und nichts mehr
möglich das heißt wir brauchen diesen
fundus und in diesem fundus sind
natürlich ganz viele mythische fragmente
unterwegs und wenn ich jetzt gleich wenn
die sendung vorbei ist zu ihnen sage ich
muss los dann wissen sie schon was ich
meine sie fragen gar nicht wieso
eigentlich und warum das heißt das war
ein kleines unruhe zitat aber sie
verstehen das ist gar nicht so
selbstverständlich alles ist gar nicht
selbst verstehen ein mensch im paradies
hätte gesagt wohin er ja ja ja ja und
diese idee diese unruhe haben wir also
mit den mythen geschichten wenn sie auch
nur noch bruchstückhaft präsent sind
aufgezogen
sie schreiben aber auch irgendwo die
mythen wird noch stärker gewisse sagen
wir sind in der zeit des logos der wir
sie glauben sie werden die mythen
stärker als andere die kraft der mieten
bis heute ja ich weil ich glaube dass es
einen fundus gibt wenn ich das eben
nannte von grundüberzeugungen ich sage
nochmal im buch etwas einen glauben denn
auch die ungläubigen teilen ja weil man
könne ja nicht allem auf den grund gehen
es wäre ja ist ja eine illusion zu
meinen wir könnten alles was uns
betrifft wissenschaftlich darstellen
ja die wissenschaft hat ja viel zu viel
hat ja alle zeit der welt wie sie würde
gar nicht fertig werden zu unseren
lebzeiten all dem auf den grund zu gehen
was uns wichtig ist und bewegt oder
woran wir uns halten und so müssen wir
also improvisieren wir müssen auf sicht
irgendetwas bewerkstelligen irgendwo
irgendeine grundlage und schaffen damit
wir den nächsten schritt tun können und
das ist bleibt alles unsicher
und so halten wir uns an
mertes oder an dinge die schon mal
funktioniert haben an traditionen oder
eben an bestimmte gedanken figuren die
wir aus sonst woher nehmen und viele
davon erstaunlich viele davon stammen
aus dem mythos
ja und wenn man sozusagen diese
funktionalität des mythos die eine
pragmatik des mythos geradezu
unterstellt man kann man relativ
entspanntes verhältnis dazu haben und
sagen das ist eine art plausibilitäten
herzustellen sowie die wissenschaft eine
andere ist oder die literatur die kunst
die religion aber sie haben gesagt der
große bogen das richtige grau ist sie
eine große story für die ganze
gesellschaft das sei heute nicht mehr
das so machen warum also dass neben
viele philosophen utopie fahrgäste ist
aber wir stimmen hier in der schweiz
bald über eine utopie leute die sagen
man sollte ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen haben ganz neu die
verteilung des reichtums organisieren
wir stimmen darüber ab also warum kann
die moderne gesellschaft keine utopien
mehr ansteuern
ich glaube sie kann sich natürlich
projekte vornehmen das würde ich schon
auch sagen und politische projekte
ökonomische projekte kulturelle projekte
selbstverständlich ja aber mit der
utopie hätte ich so meine zweifel
und zwar des hebt deswegen weil wir sehr
verkürzt könnte man sagen die geschichte
die ideengeschichte des abendlandes aber
auch unterhalb dieser ebene die
mentalitäten und so weiter wenn man das
alles berücksichtigt könnte man sagen es
ist der weg aus der determination in die
in determination in ruhe in die unruhe
von gott zu es gibt einen gott zu dem
satz gott ist tot
das ist letztlich sind das alles
beschreibungen ein und desselben
vorgangs und eine utopie muss natürlich
etwas verpflichtendes haben und deswegen
und sie brauchen eine klare orientierung
durch eine bestimmte erzählung die auf
die alle sich einlassen können ich würde
ich sagen glauben aber auf die sie sich
einlassen können diese plausibel finden
und das werden sie nicht mehr
aber die interesse zur sicherung
umfragen darauf gott ist tot finden gar
nicht alle plausibel unterschreiten
lange nicht alle wenn wir das ganze
religion sehen das aber es die kommen
nicht gleich zurück mythologisch gesehen
wie sie mal waren
sie kommen nicht mit dieser naivität
zurück des glaubens ja auch pascal
spricht ja verurteilt auch ein wenig
diesen gott der philosophen der der
sozusagen eine konstruktion ist und so
weiter mit vielen voraussetzungen
belastet und lobt dagegen auch goethe
ist ganz fasziniert davon
von dieser schlichten
glaubensüberzeugung die der wo man gar
nicht viele worte machen muss und diese
naivität diese unmittelbarkeit die fällt
uns unendlich schwer ja wir sind ja
ironiker durch und durch und das erlaubt
es nicht mehr so ohne weiteres sich auf
ein grosses auf eine große utopie
einzulassen
aber wenn mal jemand gesagt hat aber
eine ganze zivilisation anteil daran
gott ist tot dann hat man diese naivität
nicht mehr was immer man selber
letztlich auch dieser satz ja natürlich
werden immer wieder leute fragen und
auch sehr intelligente leute werden
fragen nach gott fragen ja aber sie
müssen eben anders fragen und das ist er
im grunde haben sie das handicap immer
schon in der art des zugangs ja weil
diese naivität diese unmittelbarkeit
diese fraglos sich kite nicht mehr da
ist sagen wir eines schlichten gebets
jetzt möchte ich noch mit ihnen darüber
reden welche rolle dart oder sagen wir
unsere angst vor dem tod spielt im
zusammenhang mit der unruhe also in
dieser kultur geschichte die sie so
schön beschreiben gibt es ja dann zum
beispiel auch einen wegpunkt wo max
kommt zukunft trunken auch politisch
gesehen und sagt okay da tut das ist der
harte sieg der gattung über das
individuum und damit ist also
historischen materialismus okay aber das
ist ja für viele bis heute nicht
wenn wir das als individuum sehen dass
wir können uns fast nicht wegdenken und
ein bisschen bei der lektüre des buches
oder oft hin und wieder hatte ich das
gefühl kommt die unruhe nicht auch
wesentlich davon dass ihr damit nicht
klarkommen dass alles so begrenzt ist
und darum gibt es ein gesetz weil ich
irgendwann nicht mehr sein werde
die unruhe bezieht ganz starke energie
aus dem motiv der ablenkung etwas nicht
wahr haben zu müssen sich zerstreuen zu
lassen indem amüsierbetrieb sich
auszuliefern um unangenehmes nicht zur
kenntnis nehmen zu müssen und das
unangenehmste des unangenehmen ist der
tod in unserer tradition und das
christentum hat ja lange zeit darauf die
schon zitierte antwort gegeben ruhe in
frieden das heißt der tod ist nicht das
schlimme unter das allerschlimmste
sondern es ist ein übergang und jetzt
begegnen sich die themen die wir zuletzt
besprochen haben auf der einsatz der
eine seite auf der einen seite der satz
gott ist tot und auf der anderen seite
das versprechen
du wirst die ruhe an der seite gottes
finden ja und da merken sie schon wie
die dinge auseinander gehen und wie dann
auch wieder ein tor aufgemacht wird in
dem die unruhe durch dass die unruhe
eindringen kann und sagen denkt nicht
lange darüber nach ja das ist auch ein
ganz bitterer satz pascals ja die unruhe
die zerstörer spricht dass er nennt das
phänomen zerstreuung
das ist ein angeboten nur nicht
nachdenken zu müssen ja also uns immer
abzulenken immer schon beim nächsten zu
sein während wir dies machen denken wir
schon dass das was wir gleich machen und
morgen und übermorgen was wir nicht
vergessen dürfen und so entsteht eine
karotte sierung ein nicht hier und jetzt
sein sich nicht konzentrieren zu können
und all dieses und da spielt am ende
natürlich auch die angst vor dem tod mit
die sich nicht ausleben soll sondern die
wir durch verdickungen und geschickte
manöver vor uns selbst verbergen nun
gibt es leute im silicon valley das oft
als der ort gesehen
während wo die welt im moment wieder
richtig fortschritte macht die sehr
optimistisch sind die sagen ihnen auch
das mit der kurzlebigkeit das wird
schnell besser 200 jahre liegen ring
oder vielleicht die transformer nächsten
träumen davon dass wir uns oder unsere
bewusstsein digital speichern können und
immer immer hier sein werden könnte
dieses quasi comeback der ewigkeit über
silicon valley die ausgangslage
verändern und dann ist die unruhe weg
wenn wir alle wissen wir sind sehr lange
hier und unser bewusstsein bleibt nun
viele unruh motive kommen ja in der tat
aus der einsicht dass und dass das leben
kurz sei dass man das leben nutzen
nutzen müsse und diese initiativen
scheinen ja so etwas wie eine antwort zu
geben
andererseits speisen sich diese
vorstellung muster ihrerseits wieder aus
der unruhe kultur weil es eben immer so
weitergehen soll
das heißt mir scheint das so zu sein als
würde dort eine identifikation geradezu
mit der unruhe stattfinden
diese fällt dieses phänomen gab es immer
wieder nachdem wir also alle
metaphysischen mächte erledigt haben und
alle kandidaten abtreten mussten bleibt
jetzt nur noch die unruhe selber die
unruhe ist also sozusagen die letzte
metaphysische instanz der wir uns
überlassen ja und solche begriffe wie
flexibilität mobilität diese ganze
manager sprache an die wir uns gewöhnt
haben zitiert ja bloß diesen mythos
das ist auch ein mythos dass die unruhe
er sozusagen die letzte der grund aller
gründe ist das motiv aller motive die
ursache aller usa aber die laden da
natürlich die sehr dicken war die
optimisten laden da technischen
fortschrittsglauben wieder drauf die
sachen auch die maschinen werden uns die
arbeit abnehmen und das werk ein
jammertal mehr sein ich spüre heraus so
richtig viel gewinnen sie den nicht ab
nein kann ich nicht abgewinnen weil es
ein ganz naives verhältnis zur unruhe
ist und ein
votum wäre schon auch zu sehen worauf
wir uns da eingelassen haben das heißt
aus der gefangenschaft in der unruhe
wieder herauszukommen und einem ballon
eine balance eine zeitgemäße balance zu
finden wo wir uns auf die unruhe
einlassen wollen wo wir vielleicht auch
gar nicht können als uns auf die uno
einzulassen und wo wir es aber auch mal
sein lassen könnten
und gleichsam einen vernünftigen umgang
einen besonnenen umgang mit der unruhe
zu finden
also zurück zu den alpen großen
erzählungen können wir nicht den naiven
auch mit silicon valley optimismus
angereicherten fortschrittsglauben
unterschreiben sie nicht wohin sollen in
welche richtung sollen wir gehen ich
habe ich festgestellt dass buch ist
wahnsinnig reichhaltigen der
beschreibung der unruhe und der
geschichte der unruhe und er ist kein
ratgeber aber können sie uns trotzdem
wissen sagen was richtet sie sowas ist
der kompass nun die bewusstmachung ja
das ist ja auch dass die zentrale
intuition von philosophie die dinge so
zu beschreiben dass sie uns klarer und
deutlicher werden zu der unruhe gehört
ja eben das wir blind eingewilligt haben
dass wir immer schon darin sind und dass
wir uns wenn wir uns gegenseitig
versichern dass wir jetzt nicht
schlappmachen kein moos ansetzen und was
alle so die alters ermunterung und da
der tag alltag ist voll wir verstehen
warum gar nicht nachzudenken geben wir
brauchen gar nicht nachzudenken und das
wäre jetzt eben der punkt zu
intervenieren als philosoph und zu sagen
ja was ist denn das eigentlich was uns
da treibt was auf was lassen wir uns
eigentlich ein was ist das für ein
merkwürdiger konsens in dem wir uns da
bewegen und durch bewusstmachung die
dinge so zu sagen vorziehen stellen
objektivieren erst einmal als zustand
bewusst machen um dann zu sagen wollen
wir das gibt es da vielleicht dinge die
wir nicht ganz so wichtig nehmen sollten
und so weiter und eine separate nicht
nur sinn wenn wir davon ausgehen
wir können
was daran ändern dann und das erlebt der
mensch ja nicht so als einzel mensch was
was was will ich dagegen tun
ja also auf die ebene auf der wir das
angreifen werden das ist schwierig zu
prognostizieren ja aber man kann ja in
kleinen milieus in familien in
familienverbänden verein usw kann man ja
versuchen einmal alternative dinge
durchzuprobieren und das passiert ja
auch schon dass leute jetzt eben nicht
mehr fertiggerichte machen sondern ein
mit großer freude selber kochen und so
weiter und so weiter
das heißt die leute sind ja findig in
der art und weise sich die unruhe auch
wieder auf distanz zu bringen und dieses
distanz etwas auf distanz bringen das
ist ja auch die elementare geste der
philosophie und auch ihr weg das dosiert
zu machen man hätte auch die möglichkeit
ganz auszusteigen aber aussteiger träume
haben sie nicht nur empfehlen sich als
philosoph nun das sind private lösungen
der einen für den ein oder anderen macht
das ja so eine interessante lösung sein
aber wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen
auch das abenteuer ist auch ein ganz
nettes unruhe motiv ja so dass
aussteigen auch eine sehr ambivalente
geste ist unter den voraussetzungen
jetzt dieser normalisierten unruhe
mit großem interesse habe ich gelesen es
kommt mehrfach vor im buch das ein
denker dem sie gescheite erkenntnisse
auch lebenspraktische abgewinnen wie man
umgehen könnte mit unruhe senne geist
also auch einwanderer schon ziemlich
lange nicht mehr lebt wann situieren cks
zeitgenosse jesu christi kann man ja und
der mann hatte damals schon ein konzept
das sie heute noch sehr bedenkenswert
finden ja auch weniger eigentlich das
gesamte philosophische modell senecas
seneca historiker und lebt noch ganz in
dem antiken erwartungshorizont dass die
welt ein kosmos sei das heißt dass sie
geordnet sei und dass
jedem von uns ein platz in dieser
ordnung in dieser weltordnung kosmos
heißt nichts anderes als ordnung in
dieser welt ordnung gegeben sei und
dieser gedanke hat es hat schon als
solcher etwas ganz beruhigendes das
heißt ich muss und die philosophie hilft
mir dabei nur den platz finden der meine
ist und schon darf ich erwarte neben
weil diese stimmigkeit hergestellt ist
dass ich zur ruhe komme ja so einfach
können wir es uns heute nicht mehr
machen den kosmos den gibt es noch die
physiker erklären die aber sie meinen
etwas anderes als der an der antike
kosmos dass da sind ethische motive
fließen damit ein metaphysik und meter
für sie okay das ist da noch und
schnappen wir nicht das haben wir nicht
mehr
aber was haben wir im harbour sinne hat
unendlich reiche beschreibungen gegeben
von den befindlichkeiten der unruhe hat
überhaupt diesen ganzen begriffs
apparates vokabular sowohl der ruhe als
auch der unruhe bereitgestellt und wenn
man dann hört wie in der population ogi
sich alle möglichen begriffe resilienz
oder wer sanität und wie die alle heißen
sich ab löst dann ist man erstaunt zu
sehen mit welcher sauberkeit und
präzision sie jemand wie senegal dieses
schon ausgebreitet hat und die ganzen
stufen und nuancierungen dieser
befindlichkeiten genau beschrieben hat
für seine kollegen für seine schüler und
das ist ungemein reich und anregend
bleibt es auch dann wenn wir die
hintergrund annahme einer kosmischen
autorität nicht mehr teilen
was wissen wir heute mehr über die
unruhe als auch ein anderer ganz alter
denker am anfang der geschichte der
philosophie heraklit der den berühmten
satz gesagt hat panta rhei alles fließt
ist es eigentlich immer noch die gleiche
erkenntnis mit der wir jetzt uns
arrangieren müssen oder wissen wir mehr
heute sagen wir ja wir haben mehr
erfahrung ja wir haben die ganzen
erfahrungen gemacht die terrakotta
dennoch nicht haben konnte und man darf
diesen satz auch nicht aus dem
zusammenhang reißen ja das alles fließt
das wird ja heute ganz gerne zitiert
eben von den protagonisten der unruhe
aber auch bei heraklit ist das
aufgefangen
in der erwartung dass all diese
bewegungen das all dieser wandel und
wechsel den wir beobachten und uns die
bildhaft vorstellen können wenn wir uns
einen fließenden strom denken dass all
dies aufgefangen ist durch eine gesamt
ordnung dass alles an seinem platz ist
das alles stimmt und die der der große
konflikt mit dem dass die abendländische
philosophie einsetzt ist der ob nun
dieses ganze ein sein ist steht
parmenides ist das ja oder ob es sich
bewegt oder und fließt und das ist
heraklit ja also dieser diese ganz
elementare unterscheidung zwischen sein
und werden sie speist sich aus diesem
aus diesem philosophen paar und der
konflikt lösen lektüre dieser dieser und
dieser gegen stellung und da bewegen wir
uns immer noch aber diese prämisse dass
überall dem sozusagen einer eine sichere
hand eine feine zuverlässigkeit waltet
das wird sich nicht mehr einstellen das
ist das a und das ist die verschärfung
im laufe der geschichte dass wir uns mit
der unruhe nicht mehr beruhigen können
ist es ganz zum schluss jetzt die frage
die aufgabe der philosophie und der
philosophen philosophinnen hier halt
einen ersatz zu bauen irgendwie sinn
herzustellen
nein das glaube ich nicht weil auch die
herstellung von sinn wiederum
voraussetzt
die irritation durch die unruhe und uns
dann also wenn sie die geschichte des
sind
dessen bedürfnisse berücksichtigen und
sehen dann werden sie wieder feststellen
dass erst einmal etwas verloren gegangen
sein muss so dass man also glaubt so
ähnlich wie bei den werten ist bei den
werten ist das ganz ähnlich um es dann
künstlich wieder zu erzeugen
dh der sinn verlust ist im grunde
genommen nur durch improvisationen und
ersatzlösungen überhaupt kompensierbar
und auf dieses geschäft sollten die
philosophen sich nicht einlassen sie
sollten lieber sagen dass wir den sinn
verloren haben und die anstrengungen
beschreiben die wir machen um damit
zurechtzukommen
aber sie könnten auch sagen wer die
machen soll wird die gesellschaft als
ganzes müssen lösungen finden ja und das
sind nicht nur die philosophen sondern
die die gesellschaft und die philosophen
im gespräch und eingriff in die
literatur hilft auch habe ich gelesen
ganz am schluss des buches sagen sie uns
den schönen satz noch der sie ein
bisschen tröstet einsatz von hölderlin
dahin sehr gefällt so eile denn
zufrieden ja also die formulierung ist
einfach wunderbar in ihrer stimmigkeit
und auch in ihrer leichtigkeit und ich
möchte fast sagen ohne dass das
respektiere ich ist natürlich in ihrer
dahin gesagt hat also in ihrer
lässigkeit in ihrer eleganz das ist ein
satz für den kann man nicht einstehen
man kann nur hoffen dass er das erträgt
so eile denn zufrieden hält und ihn
herzlichen dank für das gespräch ich
danke ihnen
einer der seine innere unruhe einst als
flugzeuge im bauch geschrieben der auch
andere starke metaphern in lieder goss
die ihn zu einem der erfolgreichsten
musiker europas machten herbert
grönemeyer ist am nächsten sonntag gast
in unserer sendung barbara bleisch
philosophiert mit dem hackbrett
grönemeyer über den grundrhythmus
dagegen war der schauspieler und komiker
mike müller hat sich derweil wie im
gespräch vor ihnen angesprochen fühle
mich damit befasst wie die autobahn a1
die einst beschauliche schweiz
beschleunigt hat der film a 1 ein
streifen schweitzer straße über
beschleunigung und fortschritts waren
und so von mike und seinem bruder tobi
müller jetzt gleich an
fließen dann in der sternstunde nehmen
sie es ruhig ich wünsche ihnen einen
friedlichen sonntag
[Musik]